MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
Let's start here
with a short summary.
We have seen through
experimental measurements
that there is no ether, that
electromagnetic waves travels
through vacuum.
We have discussed the concept of
the relativity of simultaneity,
meaning that two events
might occur simultaneous
to one reference-- in
one reference frame,
to one observer, while
they're not to another.
In the last two videos,
we looked at clocks.
And we've seen that
moving clocks run slow.
We've also seen that moving
objects appear smaller.
They're lengths contract.
We found that the
time of a moving clock
is related to the time
in the clock at rest
with a gamma factor
because it's time dilation.
And, for the length, we
have seen that there is a 1
over gamma dependency,
length contraction.
The entire discussion was
based on Einstein's postulates.
We simply used
Einstein's postulates.
And then we looked at
experiments of clocks.
Now, you might argue that
the setup of the clock
is actually what's
tricking us here,
but I can tell you
that is not the case.
As you have seen for
the muon, the muon
doesn't know about
optical clocks.
It just decays based
on its own properties.
I think it's fair to say that
Poincaré and Lorentz came
to similar conclusions about
the same time as Einstein did.
Delta t at rest and delta L at
rest, the time and the length,
are also sometimes called
the proper time and length.
In German-- and I actually
prefer this a bit--
we use the word eigen,
which means own.
So it's basically the time,
the own time of the object,
the object being addressed.
So we can now ask, [INAUDIBLE]
seen time is suspect.
What is not suspect?
What are the observables
which are invariant?
And, by this, I mean
the observables,
when we have two
different reference frames
and we have a conversation,
we do actually
agree in a conversation
about an observation we have.
We have seen we
cannot agree on time,
and we cannot agree on the
length in the direction
in which we are moving.
So can I ask, for
example, what happens
to the width or the height?
If I put a train on a train
track and it's fast moving,
is that contracted or even
expanded or changing at all?
The answer is no.
Similarly, if I put a
train track on a track
and I go very fast
into a tunnel,
does the height of
the tunnel change?
Also here the answer is no.
And we can verify this
later quantitatively.
In summary, transverse
dimensions are not affected.
They are not suspect.
We can agree in a
conversation of two people
in different reference
frames about the height
and the width of a train.
That's good.
But what else is invariant?
So here I want you to
consider the time and distance
between two events or
maybe even three events
observed from different
reference frames.
And we introduce or reintroduce
our characters Alice and Bob
and add Carol to this.
So we're going to have three
reference frames of three
observers in this discussion.
So I want you to look
at this one here.
So assume that Bob
has a clock, and it's
moving with a velocity v. And
Alice is observing Bob's clock.
We have done this before.
Now, we want to also
add Carol to this.
And Carol is moving with
three times the velocity
and is also observing
Bob's clock.
What I want you to do is
look at this property here.
So we have seen that
the height is invariant.
So let's look at what
happens if I calculate
2 times the height squared, and
I use x and t, time and space,
in order to express
the height, all right?
Again, this is an opportunity to
stop the clock, stop the video,
and work this out
on a piece of paper.
So it turns out
it's not that hard.
We basically find that 4
times the height squared
is equal to--
maybe it is hard--
c squared times t
squared minus x squared.
And, since the height
is an invariant,
this property, c squared,
the speed of light squared,
times the time squared minus
x squared, is invariant.
So we can think about them
as delta t and delta x.
When we look at the difference
in time and the difference
in space between two events--
Professor Klute
entered the class.
And, at the other
end of the class,
Professor Klute exploded.
If I do the delta t and the
delta x between the two--
we square them and
subtract them--
that is an observation
we can all agree on.
Whether or not you're
stationary in the classroom
or you're passing by really
quickly with your spacecraft,
that observation is
something we can agree on.
And it's invariant.
This property is called
the invariant interval.